oh dude i was thinking about this bro
maps aren't that great anymore
go look at a map dude look what's on it
mountains
mountains um what is like a wet um
slippery kind of uh river
all kind of stuff on it but not the [ __ ]
we need man i need a real
map i need to know where the uh cocaine
is
at okay can we get that on the map
okay um what's the map company merriam
webb
um miriam webster
whatever it is um
we need a map with real [ __ ] where's the
[ __ ] quicksand
y'all putting plateaus on the map i
don't give a [ __ ] about a plateau
i want to know where are all these
[ __ ] that's just going to be trying
to get at you for your money where is
that area
where is the uh people that think
they're better than everybody else
can we outline those areas around the
edges of the country
like i want a real map like where you
where are you most likely to see twins
wouldn't that be helpful because if you
riding across the country in a car or
van or something
you know or even hang gliding or
something really far
you want to be able to know where you
might be able to
you know land and see some twins
because that's the kind of [ __ ] that's
helpful
but now they got all this [ __ ] here's a
you know here's a plateau
i don't give a dang here's a national
forest
what about uh
where there's possible gold how about
that
let's make a map that's actually helpful
what about where people have
asthma and what about where
you know um
where people most likely to you know get
bit by sharks or
rabies how about showing the damn rabies
belt
how about putting stuff on a map that is
helpful to people
oh here's a um tributary i don't give a
[ __ ]
where's lil terry that's always slanging
m8 balls you feel me
why ain't he on the map
and we need new maps dude and i'll say
that right now
so mr trump why don't you give us some
new maps but i wouldn't mind a map
let me know where i could get the
freshest milk
because if you notice a lot of the milk
you get especially if you get milk at a
gas station
that [ __ ] is the
it is the bruce willis of leche
you have that should go sour in
eight hours you have eight hours to
drink any milk you get from a gas
station
go fall asleep as soon as you wake up
that milk will be sour
you know we need we need to legalize
decent gas station milk good evening
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one
ah